explosions have reportedly hit a Russian
Air Base far from the Ukrainian border
damaging two long-range bombers
unverified video of the blasts have been
posted on a variety of telegram channels
the blasts early on Monday
struck the air base near the city of
Engels more than 600 kilometers inside
of Russian territory the bombers damaged
are said to be of the same type used to
carry out air strikes on Ukraine's
infrastructure another explosion hit a
military base near the Russian city of
rayazon at least three people were
reportedly killed after a fuel tank
exploded so far there has been no claim
of responsibility for either of these
blasts so let's get more on this we are
joined by our correspondent Nick
Connelly who is standing by for us Nick
tell us a little bit more about what we
know about the explosions
yep so so far the kind of evidence we
have to go on is pretty thin we've seen
images on social media of basically some
kind of closed circuit TV cameras from
houses near That Base you just kind of
hear a big bang and some of the other
footages you see a kind of explosion of
kind of flash of light on the kind of
night sky but we have heard in the case
of Ingles from the regional Governor
telling civilians not to panic saying
pointedly that civilian infrastructure
hadn't been affected and wasn't going to
be affected so implying that definitely
there had been some kind of attack on
the military base there which is
basically one of the biggest Strategic
Air bases in Russia to where some of the
bombers that in the threat if nuclear
war became a real possibility they would
be launched from there from from planes
from that base and we've seen that base
being used to then fly uh missiles that
are aiming at Ukraine to the Caspian Sea
and launch them from so there so this is
a real kind of direct cause and effect
if indeed this is Ukraine going after
the kind of very same planes that have
been wreaking such havoc on Ukraine as
for design the other base there where we
have that Russian uh official line that
this was an explosion of a petrol tanker
but you know not many people here
believe that they say that this is
basically just a kind of fig Leaf an
attempt to kind of explain away another
Ukrainian attack whether these were
missiles or drones we don't know yet
here in Ukraine everyone is kind of
convinced that these were chemikaze
drones tell us a little bit more about
uh the response of the Ukrainian and the
Russian authorities
well so far we the Ukrainian kind of
government sources are keeping quiet
some of the kind of military bloggers
and social media accounts associated
with Ukraine's military have been
reporting on this with lots of different
Smileys and kind of ironic uh texts
accompanying these images
um I think it's unlikely that you know
Ukraine would ever kind of directly own
up to this as for the Russian side well
we've seen time and time again when
things go badly for the Russian army on
the battlefield they try to basically
keep quiet for as long as possible until
they basically make up some kind of
face-saving explanation the same was the
case when Ukraine sunk Russia's most
important battleship in the Black Sea
back in the summer took days for them to
really kind of work out what their line
would be so I think there's little uh
kind of expectation that we're going to
hear something soon but this is really
big news this is the first time that
Ukraine if it is indeed Ukraine has
attempted these kind of things that deep
in Russian territory that far away from
the front lines and it shows that
Russia's air defense just aren't up to
the task and that Ukraine is now able to
make Russia feel as vulnerable as
Ukraine itself has been feeling
vulnerable in recent weeks and months I
think psychologically I think it's
difficult to overestimate the effect of
this for ordinary Russians to see that
Ukraine is not just the place where War
happens but the Ukraine is also
potentially able to bring War to Russian
cities let's talk a little bit more
about the vulnerability on the Ukrainian
side because it's been experiencing
severe energy shortage because of the
Russian airstrikes how is the situation
where you are now
so we are now quite some time from the
last kind of major attack these Mass
missile attacks that we've been seeing
time and time again in recent months and
things are slowly getting back to normal
it's not perfect until you still have
kind of emergency blackouts when the
system is overloaded but broadly things
are getting better it is taking longer
each time for Ukraine to recover because
just basically the spare parts are
running out and the foreign help isn't
getting here fast enough but there is a
sense here in Ukraine there is also just
little point in rebuilding every time
the Russians decide to destroy this
infrastructure that actually it is now
more worthwhile going after these
Targets in Russia to prevent Russia
launching these kind of attacks but
there just aren't enough trans
Transformers enough in US equipment you
know on the world markets to keep on
rebuilding every week and you know we've
still got four or five months of winter
to go so definitely a kind of change in
mood here Nick Connelly in the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev thank you so much